hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast protecting access to
Medicare Act otherwise known as panna
the first reporting period is over but
does this legislation mean for
laboratory presented by roger clyne md
JD we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries the leading scientific social
networking websites and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
I'm julissa Meraz of labrys and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CC button
located in your bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I'd like to
introduce dr. Roger Cline dr. Klein is a
national leader in the advancements
policies related to the implementation
of genetic and genomic testing including
regulation coding and reimbursement
intellectual property and the
application of evidence-based standards
he is a national leader in the
advancement of policies related to the
implementation of genetic and genomic
testing specifically as it relates to
this webinar he has been actively
engaged in CPT coding coverage and
reimbursement issues with the College of
American Pathologists the Association
of molecular pathology and the American
Medical Association molecular pathology
cpt advisory group and governmental
panto panels such as the Medicare
evidence development and coverage
Advisory Committee he has played a
leading role in the creation and
maintenance of the molecular pathology
section in the cpt manual please join me
in welcoming dr. Roger Cline I will now
turn the presentation over to him well
everybody thank you very much for
listening today I'm going to talk to you
about the implementation of the
laboratory provisions of the protecting
access to Medicare Act one of the most
important changes to occur to the to the
payment of laboratory tests the United
States in a madrasah generation so
Medicare currently pays about seven
billion dollars and clinical laboratory
see scheduled payments per year for four
clinical laboratory diagnostic tests and
as with all other areas of Medicare
there have been fiscal strains and CMS
has been looking for ways to reduce
payments to laboratory a recent report
that was published by the office of the
inspector general suggested that
Medicare in fact was paying too much for
for some of the most commonly performed
tests as a result Congress decided to
make the clinical laboratory payment for
clinical laboratory tests market-based
and what they wanted to do was was make
the payment for clinical laboratory
tests dependent on ER or reflective of
the price is paid by in the private
insurance market to clinical
laboratories the perception was from the
OIG study that in fact Medicare was
more than private payers and n was
paying too much so some of this was
really an artifact of an inability of
the medical of Medicare to to reduce
payments in response to improving
technologies which which which resulted
in greater automation and improved
efficiencies in lower cost per test the
the legislation was enacted a nasal
first 2014 and it was part of a broader
package that was that was intended to
prolong or to reverse of a general
decline in in physician payment that had
occurred each year it was scheduled to
occur each year based on pre-existing
law it was called the st irises and me
and and that that ultimately was fixed
to follow year but in this particular
case they had tried congress has been
tried for many years to fix this the
this payment anomaly that that resulted
in me in potential of fee schedule cuts
across the board for large reschedule
cuts across the board for physicians and
and as a result they actually were
unable to come to agreement in the end
of your vote pushed ended up having to
once again reverse because as they done
by each year and this this law the
laboratory divisions were were put into
into in place in this law as an
attempted to pay for or the reversal of
or at least in part of its in attempt to
pay for the reversal of those see cuts
so with april first 2014 they were CMS
was about a year late in publishing a
final rule and and the final rule was
released in
in June of of 2016 and this risk
profoundly that this law in the end and
the subsequent rule profoundly changed
the manner in which like clinical
laboratories these gauges are real birth
in in the US and so I want to discuss
the Pamela from the perspective of the
different types of laboratories that are
impacted so we have it we have just four
forum for the sake of illustration this
presentation I'd like to break the labs
in two inches into basically four
categories independent laboratories
hospital laboratories and in the
hospital category we have both internal
internal laboratory testing performed on
internal specimens from patients with in
the hospital and outreach laboratory
will new categories of advanced
diagnostic laboratory tests of
laboratories which other labs that
perform advanced diagnostic laboratory
tests and then physician office
laboratory and and and the elements of
the legislation are really Teufel the
first is the pricing impact and so
what's going to happen to the clinical
laboratory fee schedule is going to
happen to pricing our last has gone to
be priced the other the other major
component is a regulatory component and
this mm as we'll see this gets into what
is what is required in order to
calculate the pricing or to the to
establish the pricing on a new the new
piece guys are a little laboratories
what was the role of laboratories in
helping to determine determine those
prices and then and then there's some
other other provisions that have an
impact but but probably less profound
there's some coding CPT coding or CMS
logistics coding issues and then some
coverage issues related to Medicare
administrative contractor
so how is the pricing going to be
established well this is a very very
unique unique way of pricing out medical
services and and what's going to happen
is CMS the Centers for Medicare and
Medicaid Services is obligated under the
law to calculate a volume-weighted
median of private payer rates for each
test and so well what comes to sir
private payer well in this contest in
under this law its insurer so private
insurance which we might expect who's
how health plans and then also Medicare
Advantage plans and Medicaid HMO so so
even I so even though they're truly
governmental in their funding the
Medicare Advantage plans and and the
Medicaid HMOs are included in the in the
in the rates that are going to be used
to establish with how well establish the
rate for clinical laboratories tests on
the clinical laboratory fee schedule and
then a mentor for the new category of
advanced diagnostic laboratory tests an
initial period of three quarters there
will be four initial period of three
queries will be paid it with and then
after that though they'll be jungle to
the same process where the awaited vegan
will be calculated for the advance the
diagnostic laboratory tests but what you
can see is a very different process for
this category is test and they're
actually going to get this price for the
first three quarters that's a very
favorable treatment so what what would a
CMS estimate the impact on the
industry's going to be well we're
looking at according to ms production
projection a reduction of 390 million
dollars in aggregate Part B expenditures
we're partying is the is the part of
Medicare of Medicare program that under
which CL FSS
or clinical laboratory test ok so in
2018 we're looking at at a 390 million
dollar reduction in aggregate payments
for lab tests CMS is the IMP is
estimating that five-year impact of 1.71
billion dollars and then a ten-year in
fact a 3.93 billion dollars so I'm a
four billion dollars over ten years are
expected to be reduced in the amount
that will be paid for clinical
laboratory tests based upon this movie
schedule and there are on there are
yearly limits for for the reductions to
that I from years 20 20 18 through 2020
you the test kit an individual tests
can't followed by more than ten percent
a year and then and then following that
for 20 21 through 23 they can't followed
by more than fifteen percent per year
but overall you can see that that we're
looking at pretty pretty substantial
projections projections of some
reductions in money spent on clinical
laboratory tests based upon a lower
payment so so that's the pricing
component and now we have a regulatory
component so how are they going to get
healthy and that's going to get all of
these data well interestingly there the
statute requires that they obtain the
data from clinical lab and and from what
lab well the labs from which CMS is
going to is going to obtain the data are
terms applicable laboratories and there
was some some amount of discretion CMS
has some amount of discretion in terms
of which laboratories we were required
to report from the base but in general
the structures of framework in this
statute it is actually quite
prescriptive and detailed in and
how CMS is that if they're supposed to
collect the data so the applicable
laboratories has to report the final
paid prices in volumes for each test for
each player during a six-month
collection period that then there was
some discretion I'm at the collection
period of ended up to be one 2016
January first through room january
thirtieth i'm sorry for june thirtieth
830 is so six months and and there was
so some of the CMS collected to make the
period so the collection period six
months and what labs he has to do is
they have to they have to report for
each test each text based on the cpt
code they have to report the volumes and
prices from each insurer and if there
are multiple prices from from a given
insurer which which they're likely are
in many cases they have to break down
the prices and volume for each insurer
so so if you have for prices from from
ensure a for for a given test you have
to report the prices and volume for each
of those as the lab has to be wet and
they have to include just any discounts
rebates keep on your other price
concessions and and they have a but but
it does include deductibles and
co-payments so that so that the total
rate the laboratory received is the rate
that some that that's going to be used
to establish the pricing now capitated
or bundle tests so test for example from
dr d in a hospital that way where
they're ordered as part of a hospital
stay and there's no separate payment
those are going to be excluded excluded
from reporting now test whether later on
a specific cpt code that they can't be
reported defer additive actually for
obvious reasons but there's no
requirement to report tests that are
build with unlisted codes we were
otherwise you'd have you have a
multiplicity of tests under the under
the same Kovac the prices wouldn't could
be used to calculate those forgive and
test and then beginning in january first
of 20 19 the HHS secretary
can add can can ever get reporting for
test so CMS can average reporting for
tests with different rates but for now
the first the first period labs need to
report this very very granular data will
be very very granular data now it not
not only is the requirement that there's
also a penalty for non-compliance and so
the reporting entity could could could
be subject to its possible CMS could
impose civil monetary penalties of up to
ten thousand dollars per day for each
failure to report or for each
misrepresentation or omission in
reporting applicable information so ten
thousand dollars per day for each with
representation misrepresentation a
mission is potentially a lot of money so
the possibility of dramatic penalties
cat has been included in the statute and
then the rule so CMS could act in this
manner if it so chose if it chose to do
so in the accuracy and completely
completeness of the data need to be
certified by taught by the by the
highest levels of the organization or
company either the president CEO the
chief financial officer or knit or an
individual who delegated assigned to
them but who reports directly to such an
officer so they're involving the
executive suite in attesting to the tip
to the accuracy of the data so so we
have a we have a very stringent
requirement and and actually a an
important responsibility placed at the
highest levels of the institution or
company to to comply so what is it
applicable laboratory has to report this
is a subject of considerable contention
with with this some some some trying to
argue for a broader scope of of
laboratory reporting
so that so that the pricing would be
most reflective of of the actual market
smaller labs that have to live for
example sometimes tend to be paid more
but more than than independent lesson
and of course on the other side there's
a huge regulatory burden and I think
some of the some some of the smaller
labs popular labs and smaller
independent labs didn't want to report
because they felt they couldn't comply
with the regulatory burdens and it
seemed like the lesser of two evils and
applicable laboratory is is basically a
CLIA lab an entity that owns one of more
clear laboratories that fills the
Medicare Part B the Medicare program
upbeat for laboratory tests under its
own national provider as identification
number it's on NPI so they defined
applicable laboratory at the NPI level
and you have to get a majority greater
than fifty percent the lab has
conspirators and fifty percent of us
Medicare revenues from Part B which is
the clinical laboratory schedule or the
physician fee schedule and then the
clinical laboratory see schedule revenue
needs to be greater than 12,500 dollars
per year so again the entities the
Rhodope lickable labs to find that the
NPI level you have to have greater than
half of the revenue coming from either
physician services or lab services or
from the other services on Part B and
then and then the reporting itself is at
the taxpayer ID level and and so if a if
a company for example has multiple labs
that report under different NPI's the
reporting itself would be done at the
level of the company well the applicable
laboratory definition is at the level of
the NPI number and so how would a lab
then go about deciding whether or not
they are inapplicable laboratory the
first thing you're going to look at is
the left clia-certified do we have a
clear certified lab and then what you
want to do is you're going to need to
look at the NPI
under which the lab bills and so so
dramatically a certificate and then if
you do what what's the NPI member that
you bill so if you bill under a hospital
NPI it's unlikely that you will be and
it's like the laboratory because part a
revenue will be likely overwhelm the
Reaper fee revenues and Part B revenues
are less will probably be less than
fifty percent so a hospital laboratory
way a laboratory in the hopper or
associated with as well but those are
their hospitals mpi likely won't be
applicable you look you then looking
once you identify the mpi our fifty
percent of the total Medicare final paid
claims from Percy or the CFS position
seat service and so what you do then is
you'll take the NPI CLS S&P SS final
paid claims divide that by the total
Medicare revenues for the NCI including
deductibles and copays and you'll have
your answer and again so for an
independent laboratory that's just
mostly providing let clinical lab
services or laboratory and example
pathology services that are billed under
the physician fee schedule essentially
all of their claims are going to be
Third beat again in a hospital if you're
a hospital-based lab it probably and
your billing at the level of that
Haskell MPI most of the hospital Rogan
is not going to be peppy and the
majority of how thoroughly won't be
perfectly and we won't be inapplicable
laboratory finally and this is most
relevant to a physician office
laboratory as a clinical laboratory fee
schedules at least 12,500 dollars and so
so this can actually be a very complex
analysis this chair is really meant to
just to illustrate a large integrated
health system with this was a
institution with which I was involved we
get over 200 CLIA lab clear licenses
link over 220 in within the institution
so basically each one of those three
licenses needed to be evaluated to see
whether or not they were part of it a
flip were or peridot world work will in
a quick 11 fibroma little book
applicable left so the previous analysis
the mpi that are needed to be done for
each Cleo license a method that's what a
health system or a hospital will need to
do because so this is it should be
apparent create substantial compliance
class the clinical laboratory fee
schedule is grown from 1400 folks from
400 to over 1300 tests each puts the web
is estimated those at least around 1500
a different private insurers and it
approximately 25 tests on counselor
eighty-five percent of the total around
services so then you have a bunch of
many other potential test scattered with
with much lower volume so so you have a
lot of data points and CMS is estimating
600 million total data points collected
so labs have tikl applicable labs have
to collect 600 million total data points
and then cmss they accurately evaluate
them to obtain the weighted media so so
what's the impact of the low in the
lower expenditure expenditure threshold
as I suggested how this is mostly
applicable to physician office
laboratories so there are approximately
two hundred sixty-six thousand unique
MPI metal enemies enrolled in Medicare
as a laboratory and paid under the
current the laboratory fee schedule now
most of those labs are physician office
was ninety-three percent are enrolled
exposition office lab only one percent
are enrolled as independent laboratories
and then six percent of other tries to
learn such as rural clinics or skilled
nursing facilities now Oh CMS is
estimating only five percent of position
office LEDs will actually be inflexible
laboratories that's about twelve
thousand four hundred labs but those
labs will come for ninety two percent of
the Taylor's of statics ELSS spending a
position that other side so basically
there's a small very small number of
large the physician office lab that are
going to have to report most will not
will not be reporting and only forty
five percent of the applicable of the
independent laboratories will be
applicable list that's about 1200
independent lab it's going to include
about 99% almost all of the CLS are
spending I mean I'm independent lab so
but but it's only it's less than 0.5% of
the total labs so so they're really
capturing large laboratories and here's
the schedule we serve discussed this a
bed on the data collection period was
last year a general first in june
thirtieth and then there was a six-month
window six months six months window
after that and data there is a data
reporting period the data reporting
period was originally scheduled to be
this year from January first 2017 to
March 31st 2017 and those data would
actually be used to calculate the
clinical laboratory see schedule for of
2018 through 2020 and then and then
after that another data collection
period take is it takes place and that's
uh january twenty nineteen through june
generous first 20 19 through june
thirtieth 2019 and then was the same
period of window period and then again a
reporting period in 2020 of from january
first to march 31st and then those those
data will be used to calculate the fee
schedule for 20 21 and in the the three
years inconclusive of that and and then
so CMS has set up an electronic portal
for the laboratory to register and you
can you can you can find you can find
this this this i'm the CMS website so so
laboratories will need to register and
then CMS set up a reporting template for
for including the styles you can you can
submit you or you need to submit
electronically and the data points um
obviously if you have a lot of data
point do you prefer to enter them enter
them electronically so there's a process
for at least attempting to and probably
kettering most of the data points but
the idea would be to to to take those
values and enter them electronically as
much as possible into the CMS reporting
template so let's going to be the effect
of all of this I'm clinical laboratories
well so starting off then with the
independent laboratory so the smallest
labs about fifty-five percent of the
total will that one percent I spared
this regulatory burden so they don't
have to do this exhaustive reporting
with which is it's going to be very very
difficult to comply the largest labs and
specialty labs are best able to meet the
reporting requirements the so so that
that's who's going to be doing the
reporting if there are some of the
smaller independent labs that have to
have some hell that do have to report
are going to be faced with some
substantial new new regulatory cloth
then we have the hospital lab well so
hospital laboratories are probably
spared the regulatory burden in most
cases some was was probably the largest
outreach program where they would be
billing under a separate NP I will have
that regulatory burden that they're
going to need to do the reporting but in
general I think hospitals are spare the
reporting 30 mostly physician
laboratories 95% won't have to do this
reporting so from a regulatory
standpoint the reporting m and the
regulatory pieces is focused on out a
much more narrow group of laboratories
that are larger and but but involved
actually hi what appears to be out
a very high percentage of the Medicare
submitted claims I'm hospital
laboratories perform a lot of tests but
but most of those and more than an
independent laboratories do but but most
of those are performed as part of a
bundle either on the on the impatient
see schedule as part of a diagnostic
related group of bundled payment or on
the outpatient prospective payment
system where where those tests are also
bundled into the into the ambulatory of
payment classification so that's the
regulatory pictures and then all the
labs are going to be subject to a
reduced what appears to be able to do is
clinical laboratory fee schedule that
resembles with the pricing of the
largest independent laboratory some
contrast between those labs and will are
just ensures since the data points are
going to come from the primarily from
the largest lab and they're there if
it's likely that they're going to be
reflective of the ultimate pricing
assembly reflective of the prices those
laboratories charge through contracts
with the largest insurers and so we're
likely to see significant declines in at
least aspects of the clinical in place
the schedule most notably the automated
tests that have from that level price
many years ago and have never had their
prices reduced in in accordance with
changes in technology if it seems likely
that for most tested the pricing is prob
they're going downward pressure on
pricing but it's possible some tests
could in fact a lot some of the
molecular tests like next-generation
sequencing where the pricing on the CMS
pricing seems to be low it's possible
that that that those prices will go up
there certain individual tests that that
are that are appear to be paid higher
than Medicare fee schedule a private
payers so we don't we don't know yet
we'll have to wait till we see the data
but in general expect largely say
substantial pricing decreases in
aggregate
traded probably most heavily on that
test overpriced launder a long time ago
and are heavily automated butt lifts
with potential impacts across the board
for foremost test so what does this mean
an aggregate to the laboratory industry
for the website field it suggests that
the current trends toward consolidation
of laboratories elected to continue this
may very well accelerate accelerate
their trend in particular looking at
hostel outreach programs for example
you're going to it has to outreach
programs that need to report for may may
well decide that that that the
combination lower prices plus this
increased increased burden is something
they're they're they're just not
interested in engaging anymore and and
and that may also be the case admit it's
made small with smaller in a sentiment
that night just say well you've got this
huge reporting burden and the this these
declines in the fee schedule in this
this really isn't a profitable business
for its anymore those so so we're going
to acetate or going to sell out to one
of the larger labs but I think that this
is this this is an environmental and if
it is an is an environmental incentive
or a push towards further consolidation
in the clinical laboratory industry ok
so just getting to the advanced
diagnostic laboratory chapter a blt
these are a very narrow class of tests
written sort of modeled after expressed
gene expression profiling test where
they had multiple of four general
multiple expression levels RNA
expression levels obtained and then they
use a complex statistical algorithms to
to combine the levels of all of those
biomarkers components into a risk score
I think that that would be the prototype
of enzymatic laboratory tests by
definition there they're offered and
furnished by a single developing
laboratory that's a legal definition and
and there these are going to be defined
at the mt level the lab I so so so if
you're offering tested its defined as an
energy level at the energy level
importantly for CMS is defined advanced
diagnostic laboratory tests with again
remember they get favorable treatment of
narrowly in some ways and and for
example license test so if you have a
test of what otherwise meet the criteria
but it's like you to the University many
of these types of tests are developing
epidemic cards those wouldn't be
considered a advancing active laboratory
test because they're licensed they're
not developed by the individual by the
original developing laboratory what's so
so by definition these are going to be
again offered by a signal original
developing laboratory and then they beam
through an analysis of multiple
biomarkers and DNA RNA and our protein
so it doesn't have to just be gene
expression it can be a multiplicity of
markers and then you better combined
with the unique algorithm that yields a
single unique patient specific result
and it has to provide new clinical
information that can't be obtained from
other tests or combination of tests or
the other options be that it could be
the test could be offered in furnished
by single developing laboratory but then
if it's FDA approved it clear that could
also be considered and maybe guilty so
those are the those are the ADL teeth
which is designated for for special or
improved treatment under under this law
relatives relative to what I want to
thank was always perceive to be less
complex and and potentially more more
routinely performed broader most
performed by much larger numbers of
laboratories
test so to test those that are performed
by again by larger numbers of labs and
and and would be more routinely
implemented and less complex that that
means then then what what what they're
saying is a diagnostic laboratory tests
are but this is business law and mrs.
this is it's what the statute says so so
from payment standpoint the ADL teams
will basically if there's no payment
under the CFS before january first 2018
so next year so basically tested hasn't
yet been been paid by Medicare they're
going to get the actual list price for
the first three quarters of the year and
that's their initial period and after
that they're the same type of process
will be used to calculate their weighted
median for the individual test now this
is a favorable treatment in some
respects because many of the private
insurers may infect you the list or the
Medicare rate to set their own rights
and so and so you're really looking at
you're looking at a potential ground
basis or a ground groundwork for for
having a higher level of reimbursement
so there is a provision for for bringing
back some of some of that money is in
fact but for recouping some of that
money is in fact the tests turn out to
be the list price tense turns out to
overestimate significantly what the was
a the established rate for private
payers ends up to be and so it's greater
than a hundred and thirty percent that
difference is then going to be recouped
by Medicare
the end of the lowest mountain on and
the congressman it with respect to a
favorable provisions of the low
expenditure threshold with twelve
thousand five hundred dollars doesn't
apply to the a blt so when it when a new
test comes out of nukes and a new
clinical laboratory diagnostics a
clinical diagnostic laboratory test
comes out we have this this once every
three years process of determining
prices how are you going to determine
the pricing of new tests to come out
well it's going to be pretty much the
same way it's now I'm either a process
called cross swapping where they take
the existing test or combination tests
that are have similar methodology the
resources and that serves as the basis
for payment so looking at existing tests
and using prices that have been
previously paid for some more tests or
or testa that I run that are comfortable
so that they can they can extrapolate
those data to I just at the price and
then there's process called gasoline and
these are contractor established payment
amount them and there's a bunch of
criteria that they use in in terms of
resources to perform the test what other
payers provide and they look they look
at agglomeration of factors and then the
contractors from self to Medicare
military contractors establish their own
own payment amounts so this is this is
really what what's been done now this is
how initial payments been set now that
really hasn't changed other than the
fact that there is an advisory panel
that set up that can provide that that
will provide the input input into this
process they don't have the authority to
set the prices the CMS can can at least
obtain the advice from experts in the
field that can help tell them how to
help them with their pricing levels and
tell them what method whether you cross
walking or a gap filling and the CMS
isn't bound by the advisory channel
but but but they do that but I have an
opportunity to take advantage of that
expert input and then also they they're
required to have a public exploration
attainment rate and so how the gasoline
criterion and then panel recommendations
are applied and so this is was
previously applied for crossref test but
I think I not not so much the gap
filling process what are some of the
coding changes in this in this law well
I CMS provided that the statute provided
the CMS has to create new codes to
identify each new advanced diagnostic
laboratory tests and any new FDA cleared
or approved test these will be temporary
codes and and American medicine the
American Medical Association CPQ process
actually has come up with a way to to do
this through oracle PL a code the and i
think i think the intent of CMS appears
to be to try to work with AMA and anto
to let but I am I carry as much of the
burden of this or do as much of the work
on this is as as they can they can feel
they can they can use ISM this is an
enormous potentially enormous task and
and and the existing cpt code structure
i think has his work worked well the the
secretary needs to is supposed to
announce a unique istics code and report
payment amount for each existing a blt
suppose it that already exists but i'm
going through this price setting of
process because there they've been paid
before january 2018 and for each
existing afda
clear to approved test which medicare
has been is made has been paying as a
april first 2014 that these already
don't have unique codes the vendors hit
really the receptor really is on the
vendors to themselves of these tests to
obtain because if they want them I think
there's there's appears that it's
probably limited or there may be there
may be limit eligibly limited limited
demand because I think though you know
the CPP process may be working well for
many of these and then CMS does you
don't have to guess to have some
mechanism of the issue a unique
identifier for tracking purposes most
leaves of these see blts with respect to
the minute Medicare administrative
contractors just say a couple words of
the Secretary of HHS at CMS was
authorized to to designate up to form
contractors to establish local coverage
decisions for clinical laboratory
diagnostic tests or to establish local
coverage decisions and process claims so
either to establish coverage and profit
splinter or simply to simply there to
establish coverage CMS elected not to
use the authority at this time they
could in the future but right now well
then they've chosen not to act and this
on this authority as such so what's
happening so the title of the talk and
this is when we sent it in was that the
reporting periods over well they're
pouring here is not over folks and what
happened was was I think laboratories
experience greater difficulty then was
anticipated and reporting was skewed
toward the end of the period I think him
and I I don't have numbers one can't
help but suspect that potentially some
labs have a
been able to gather this data
insufficient time to report but anyway
CMS has announced a 30 a 60-day period
or delay in in requiring the reporting
so let's have another couple months
together their data to present their
data and to include their data I don't
think this should have been a surprise
necessarily because of similar in there
was a civil there's a similar law in
California and laboratories were
supposed to repay report report their
pricing data and only nine percent of
those that was supposed to report did I
think laboratories in general have them
has a substantial problem reporting data
with this degree of granularity of their
systems of may not allow for and uh
certainly within hospitals there's a
consider their you're getting payment
sources from payments some internally
from from difference or some of them may
be may actually be out of bundle
payments and I think that the system's
don't don't many systems don't capture
the degree of granularity for example
where they're able to take each plane
from each payer and lump those into the
ones they're the same and the ones that
are different break them apart and so
the a what it sounds like is that
laboratories have had to did this has
been very arduous or even even very
highly sophisticated list and to require
a lot of manual attention to the
individual claims and I n so CMS has
elected to to give lived another another
couple months too well to comply so then
so just to summarize than the the
assessment this really dramatic dramatic
change in in pricing for clinical
laboratory tests and and and and and the
nms some there this this potentially
huge huge structural in position in the
in the in the field because of the
yeah because of both pricing effective
regulatory sex what we're likely to see
are significant decreases in clinical
laboratory fee schedule pricing that's
going to move the fee schedule for
pricing of the largest independent
laboratories this is this would be
expected to be most common among the
highest volume automated tests that will
priced long ago or many years ago mm and
those ten those tests are likely to see
the greatest impact but but this may
well occur across the board for most
tests there's a substantial regulatory
burden of reporting for applicable
laboratories it was a larger labs even
though even though they have more data
points seemingly better equipped to meet
the mandate there is a threat of sizable
penalties for years and they're porting
now you know I think CMS has indicated
that unless in situations where where
there's been a good states effort to
comply they're not likely to to impose
serious penalties but nevertheless the
threat of penalties does exist and for
those labs that are reporting one
doesn't know what what's likely to
happen I know you know it's 92 only nine
percent reported in California and
they're extending the deadline for 60
days it one suspects that there's
probably a number of labs that we're
supposed to have been reporting that
hasn't reported yet from an aggregate
industry perspective these these forces
seem likely to help promote
consolidation among labs and a trend
that's been ongoing i think i think this
the new fee schedule may accelerate this
this consolidation and then a blts of
those that have him controlling pests to
meet the relatively stringent are
actually quite rated criteria for brady
lt's that that CMS it has set up i can
qualify for for favorable treatment that
that should help from accelerate and
promote
the growth of those types of stuff
assuming they can they can be there that
they're actually that they can meet the
general of evidence standards for by
which which medical procedures including
tests are judged and with that time I
will conclude and I'll be happy to take
questions thank you talk to clients of
that informative presentation it's time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. Klein please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for if you are
unable to get to your question today dr.
Klein will follow up with you via email
after the presentation so let's get
started our first question is if I want
additional information where can I find
it there's done a really good job sorry
CMS has done an excellent job of
creating a website so you can just put
in Google put in CMS and Pamela and it
will take it to their website they have
they've got they not only do they have
the legislation will rule but they've
got frequently asked questions document
they have they have a number of advisory
transmittal notices and and and and
other other documents to help health
laboratories and help help folks working
in this area 22 to comply with and to to
make sure that that that they're
properly
the submitting day and and that they're
properly analyzing their situation and
and so I i would encourage anybody who
i'd encourage everybody to actually pay
a visit to that site it's a it's just a
wealth of resources for you great thank
you for that will wrap up with another
question and that question is is it
possible that CMS will delay the
implementation of the rule for the first
year question so a number of
stakeholders have been asking for this I
think I think there's pretty much I
think there's some consensus in the in
the laboratory community that this that
accomplishing this reporting is is more
difficult than individuals and companies
they had a and CMS actually had had
imagined and I think I think that well
they'd be the entire the entire lab
industry it has been nice I believe this
is as United or much of the web industry
I can't come to everybody but much of
the web industry is it has expressed a
desire to four per CMS to delay
implementation another year I don't know
whether or not they can or will be
willing to do do so I if you point if
you look at the language in the and
their 60-day extension rather than
saying that they're going simply saying
they're going to delay implementation or
going to wait extend the period for
collection of data they said that
they're going to use in what's called
enforcement discretion meaning they're
not going to
action against lab until for 60 days
even though the reporting period has
ended that suggests that that
potentially some within the agency feel
sufficiently bound by statute that they
don't think they can can go ahead and
extend this further without
congressional action that's that simply
my own excess or potentially a hunch I
don't have any particular knowledge of
that but but I think the language of the
delay suggest that that co CMS may be
concerned that they're not that that
that it's that they're another delay I
mean they've already delayed in a year
that another delay is too much because
they're really not they would be really
deviating from the statutory
instructions again which were which were
will that this was going to be
implemented last year to send it another
year they may feel this is too long but
i don't know i can't speak for firmly
campus of agency for CMS but i thought
but i suspect that if i was officially
if your clinical lab and you're
wondering and hoping whether or not
they'll extend it i am and you're you're
thinking about not submitting or not
working on your data i would consider it
a wise to do the best you can to submit
your data great thank you so much for
that answer i would like to once again
thank dr. Klein for his presentation do
you have any final comments okay thank
you very much for listening it this is
this is a really interesting time in May
and I think in the history of the
laboratory industry and most of us have
been been sitting and focusing on
providing the best services we can for
patients this is this is some this is
something that I think a lot of us don't
have experience with in and really
understand
payment system generally mmm and the
first introduction that I think many
people are getting is to a very here
accomplice to murder to this process
that that that that's going to represent
real challenges I I think on the one
hand it's fortunate that see a message I
can see my system wise in restricting
the number of labs to that need to
report but it's going to but that's
going to have an impact on the fee
schedule it's going it may well result
in in lower prices than otherwise would
have would have occurred in had had
everybody or a broader set a broader
Russell section of lab so reported but
so far I think that you know I think I
think they're doing a good job and and
and I think and really I think CMS
recognizes how hard this isn't and I
would encourage laboratories that that
need to report that to do the right
analysis and and do the best you can
thank you once again dr. Klein I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through july in 2017 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye
you